who are the top 5 best known users in
Hunter Hunter simple question but very
complicated answer mostly due to the
vagueness of the word best and what
being the best entails but there is
actually a canonical answer to this
question now bear in mind that this is
hearsay but a certain biscuit Kruger
once claims that another certain Isaac
National had constructed his own top 5
best known users in the World list which
does make natural sound a bit like a
YouTuber but he actually did this and
not only that but it's heavily implied
that he considers these five people to
be even more powerful than him and I use
the word powerful on purpose because
when talking about nen strength and
power are only one of the many factors
to consider however netro's definition
of the best nen user is unsurprisingly
heavily tainted by his own personal bias
towards power now Toro's entire life was
about seeking out the strong and then
punching slapping and generally thacking
them with golden statue arms however in
chapter 202 natural claims that nefepito
is likely stronger than him to which nov
says surely you just in a very upper
class old money kind of way off to which
point netro says that it's been at least
half a century since he was considered
to be the most powerful nen Master again
I want to linger on that word powerful
because when it comes to the best nen
users netro's metric is power which is
why that's exactly what we're going to
be using to determine natural's top 5
list I should also say that netro is a
notoriously unreliable source of
information in fact in the same page he
states that moral enough are likely
evenly matched with him at this point
which we all know is absolutely not true
I guess it's probably worth noting that
Natori can't just whip out his marrow
and performance at any given time and he
needed to meditate intensely to reach
that state but still he is very powerful
and a very sneaky prune and so we're
going to need to sift through his
modesty and or blatant lies but assuming
that his statement to biscuit was true
netro genuinely considers there to be
five nen users in this world that are
even more powerful than himself and our
first confirmed candidate is none other
than Jing freaks in fact that guy he's
how the whole discussion came about gone
asked bisky in chapter 138 whether or
not she knew Jing which the answer was
no but she knew of jinx specifically
that Isaac Nitro once labeled him as one
of the world's top 5 best known users so
that was an easy start usually in these
videos I need to make extensive
semiological arguments to support my
statements but this is just outright
factual natural labeled Jing as one of
the top five natural's metric for nenues
power and therefore Jing is potentially
even more powerful than the Isaac Nitro
we knew which if true is exceptionally
impressive mainly because Jing is only
34 years old whereas the path of the nen
Master tends to Peak closer to the 50s
and 60s but in any case our drink
sipping suit wearing Panda owning Jing
freaks will assume his place in the top
five a big part of this video was also
determining who can't possibly be one of
these candidates and so I think we
should briefly discuss the Chimera ants
they are obviously not going to be
considered in this discussion simply
because netro's list was constructed
prior to their existence in a more
modern setting meruim and perhaps all of
the royal guard would slot comfortably
into the top five but that's not what I
want to know what I want to know is who
were the top five at the time of Greed
Island because I think that is
infinitely more interesting given that
we've started with the Zodiac I think
it's more than reasonable to continue
with them as a fierce rival of Mr Jing
Paris and Hill is naturally going to
slide himself into the conversation like
a well-lubed rat he's often considered
to be exceptionally powerful because of
one of the zodiac requirements that
requirement being that each and every
one of them need to be available to spar
with netra that's why he made them
that's why he does everything to find
strong people to fight but if pariston
is truly powersome then he hides it very
very well such as in chapter 343 where
pariston asserts his position as second
in command of the Dark Continent
Expedition team to which Jing retorts so
it's not a hierarchy of strength then in
fact Jing initially identifies Marion as
the most powerful member of the
Expedition team who is the robot Doll
Girl thing Harrison as always is
difficult because he often claims that
he's weak but he also often contradicts
Us by accusing people of grossly
underestimating him and with that I
can't say I'm confident in labeling him
as one of the top five because it really
could go either way and I have to say
the rest of the zodiacs don't do much
better which we know thanks to hisoka's
personal grading system John kanzai and
ginto were rated by our Battleground
receiving a 77-85 and 90 respectively
which all sounds nice and amazing until
dick wanders in and registers as a 95
and I personally don't think that illumi
makes netro's list there are just way
too many other candidates in fact many
of which are older zoldx however I do
believe that there is one more zodiac
who could possibly have attained one of
these spots his name is bought by
Gigante and he was not subject to
hisoka's rating system however he is
subject to a disputed translation when
announcing one of the election rounds
Spotify was labeled as advisor to The
Zodiacs and close to the previous
chairman that's the official translation
so it makes netro and bottibai sound
like cold Chum friends however other
translators have actually disputed this
and claimed that it more accurately says
something like both in name and reality
this man is the closest to the chairman
which annoyingly can also be interpreted
in many different ways it could be
implying that there's some sort of
equivalent in power it could also be
referencing their functional abilities
used as a chairman you know
Administration leadership and the stuff
but again it could just be implying that
they're old friends what tips me over
the edge though is that butterby is an
undisputedly combat focused nen user he
is a Triple Star terrorist Hunter with
roles specifically relating to military
security and Justice of all of the
zodiacs he's the one who exudes the most
power he's also the oldest being 50
which is prime then age having lived
long enough to master the art form but
not having lived quite long enough to go
into elderly decline as netro had I
think it's perfectly reasonable to
incorporate bottabay into the top five
because he's about as powerful as you
can get within the association unless
you're netro or allegedly Jing but it's
not all about the hunter Association in
fact many of our most powerful nen users
exist completely separate to the
association with one of the next natural
assumptions being to examine the Phantom
troop specifically crawler you know one
of the weird things about Hunter Hunter
is that the Phantom troop and the hunter
Association have never really collided
that's yeah they've done that they've
not quieted it if the closest we've come
is both groups now being aboard the
Blackwell one but as a result we we've
never gotten any insight into what
higher level Association members think
of the truth and they do think that
crawler could be considered one of the
best net users by my own personal
criteria but I just don't know if he has
the raw power that netro would have used
as a metra and if he did we don't know
if netra would have been familiar enough
with crolo to make that judgment if we
were to use hisoka scale crollo likely
sits a couple of points higher than
illumi maybe a 96 or a 97 which is why
hisoka chooses to pursue him over anyone
else but when it comes to netro I just
can't see crawler being on his mind
someone he is very familiar with however
is netaro's own son Beyond nettero and I
mean it's all in the name really tagashi
is often very blunt with this sort of
information Beyond is almost certainly
more powerful than the Isaac natural we
knew because Beyond is like Isaac nashro
in his prime Beyond is somewhere in his
60s or 70s as opposed to at least the
112 years old that Isaac was so beyond
is still comparatively youthful and in
fact he's around half a century younger
than Isaac at least which is the time
period where Isaac natural identified
himself as being the most powerful nen
user although even 50 years ago Beyond
was powerful enough to survive a Voyage
to the Dark Continent and at this point
he is practically guaranteed to be one
of the top five he's not the only one to
survive a Dark Continent Voyage though
in fact netro's companions on one of his
journeys are still alive and well one
lynnae or Dev and Zig zodik who is very
much implied to be Maha zoldik I'm not
going to go into why and how because
it's a long story I have a whole
separate video about it but trust me
it's very convincing but at one stage I
would not be surprised if this Trio were
considered part of the top five or even
the top three themselves however just as
with Isaac natural lynnae and Zig have
since endured the ravages of age if
netro picked 50 years ago then so did
they no doubt still very powerful but
unlikely to be sitting quiet at the top
and I would argue that the most powerful
current zodik is Zeno sitting at the
again comparatively youthful age of 69
which sounds really old Until you
realize that Maha Sig is at least 50
years older than that but Zeno is
objectively one of the most powerful nen
Masters we've seen provided we discount
the Chimera and and the dark consonant
creatures and the argument again Xeno is
usually the crowler fight the fact that
he had a lot of difficulty facing that
their crowler even two on one with Silva
and Xeno did also state that the fight
would be entirely different if croler
were actually trying to kill him but I
do think that this is very inconsistent
with Xena's portrayal in future rocks
fun fact now Xeno is the only character
in Hunter Hunter to realize that he's
actually a character and start speaking
directly to the readers during which he
described his relationship with Isaac
Nitro as being yin and yang but also
making sure to State don't be stupid
we're not equals he's always gotten the
best of me but the very fact that Xeno
has fought netro on multiple occasions
and experienced the 100 type guanine
borisatva speaks volumes about his own
personal power Xeno is so so so much
more than what we saw in that fight
against crawler and I think that this is
a tagashi inconsistency issue and if
every character we currently know I
think that Xeno is one of the most
likely to be one of netro's top 5 best
known users however I would add that
netra was probably being very modest and
very sneaky very deceptive by not
including himself on that list but
provided that we take his word at face
value we run into an interesting
situation to find our final candidate at
this point I would like to introduce you
to the concept of the Togashi power
chart a fan compiled data set of
information gathered from the official
hunt Hunter databoy it's deceptively
named because it's not known if tagashi
produced this information himself he may
very well have because he's done similar
things in the past he does have internal
notes regarding Nan powers and use and
where people are graded with their A's
their B's the C's and the numbers but
this data analyzes then uses based on
six criteria each being scored out of
five for a potential maximum of 30
points which netro does achieve I should
note that characters like marowen and
Gyro do not appear in the set marowen
because his abilities were so far off
the scale that they simply can't be
Quantified and Gyro because his
abilities were left tantalizingly
mysterious but if we look at the rest
under natural of the royal guard who
wear discounting but the next highest
ranked nen user is very surprisingly
bisky who scored a whopping 26 points
according to this biskey is a better
then user than crowler who scored 25
which Joe you know you know we're fine I
can absolutely believe that whiskey is
59 years old again smack bang in that
Peak Nan Mastery Zone and she is
incredibly powerful as well as a close
associate of natural so I could
definitely see her being in the top five
at the time of Greed Island so let's say
that tagashi did make these charts which
I tend to believe he probably did
however even then it's a painfully
selective data set because so many
characters were left out for whatever
reason for example other than kilowatt
no other zoldx are racked which is a bit
weird because we've known them since
practically the beginning of the series
and illumi in particular is a staple of
Hunter Hunter so all of them could be
well and truly above biscuit but
according to the evidence we have I have
no choice but to seriously and I mean
seriously consider biscuit Kruger for
our fifth slot and really there's only
one other option I can think of and it's
it's a bit of a long shot but there is
at least one lurking legend in the hunt
hunt world who may be known to netro and
that is Don freaks a man who would be
over 300 years young if he was still
alive at this point but also a man who
would likely be the most powerful men
using human to have ever existed apart
from Jesus Jesus is canonically a nen
user and if you want to know more about
that you can check out some of my
Iceberg videos there's some really fun
information in there but netro has been
to the Dark Continent twice so it's not
entirely inconceivable to think that he
may have met Don however given the
Colossal size of the continent the idea
of them simply running into one another
is a little bit far-fetched but
excluding the potential of Don these are
my proposed top 5 best known users
according to both the criteria of Isaac
natural and the available evidence we
have let me know what your top five are
in the comments below or not go watch
another video I don't care what you do
with your day